ينضم الينا من موسكو اندرياس الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا
حصيله كبيره عدد كبير من القتلى في هذه
المنطقه في في دونيتسك ما تفسيرك لما جرى
للاسف انها حرب في الحرب هناك ضحايا من
المستحيل ان يكون هناك ان تكون هناك حرب
بدون ضحايا ولكن اريد ان الفت الانتباه
هنا الى ان الرقم رغم انه رغم ان الرقم
كبير ولكن هذا رقم غير كبير بالدرجه التي
تعلن عنها
الاوكرانيه همم انهم فقط 63 شخص حسب ما
اعلن المصدر الروسي الرسمي لا تعتبر ان
هذا الرقم كبير في حصيله قتل ليوم واحد
هذا كما قلته عدد كبير من الضحايا ولكنه
ليس كارثيا او عظيما بالدرجه التي تعلن
عنها الاوكرانيا بالنسبه للجيش الروسي هذا
عدد كبير من الضحايا ولكن هذا قلبك كثير
اقلبي قليل بكثير عفوا من ما يخسره القوات
البركانيه عن ما يقوله الاوكرانيون ما
يقوله الروس الان بان ال ال الاسلحه التي
تم استخدامها واستهدف بها هذا العدد
الكبير من المجندين كانت صواريخ هاي مارس
الامريكيه لماذا برايك تم توضيح هذه
النقطه في بيان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عتيقه
الوسائل الوحيده والمعدات الوحيده الدقيقه
الموجوده لدى القوات الاوكرانيه والتي
ممكن ان تقصف مواقع في الخطوط الخلفيه
الروسيه لان القوات الاوكرانيه ليس لديها
اي معدات متطوره لذلك ضربته هجمات من هذا
النوع
حسب
اعلنته
الوزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها صواريخها
هايمارس نحن نعلم انها صواريخ تاتي من
الولايات المتحده ولذلك وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تريد ان تؤكد ان الولايات المتحده
طرف في هذا النزاع وبالتالي ما هو رد
الفعل المتوقع من موسكو على هذه الخطوه
يعني
لا اعتقد انه سوف يكون هناك رده فعل
استراتيجيه لانه للاسف هذه الضربات
بالمواقع المدنيه تستمر لعده اشهر ولكن من
وجهه النظر التكتيكيه وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه سوف تقوم بزياده عدد انظمه الدفاع
الجوي التي سوف تكون متواجده في تلك
المناطق وتعلمون ان الهايمرز هي اهداف
شرعيه بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه لذلك سوف
نستخدم المزيد من المعدات اللي ضربها
هل هناك
تحذير
للجانب الامريكي من خلال هذا الاعلان
لعدم مد كيف بمزيد من الاسلحه عندما تعلن
موسكو بانه نحن نعلم ما السلاح المستخدم
في استهداف جنودنا فعلى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تحذر من المزيد من الامداد
العسكري
لاوكرانيا هل هذه رساله تفهم من بيان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
في هذا الاعلان اعلنا ما نريده وان
ااا الروسي قلق بالنسبه للمعدات التي تمد
بها الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا وتحدثنا عن
هذا كثيرا ولكن هذه الحاله الماساويه
تحديدا لا لا تعتبر احد هذه الاعلانات ان
الدعم
الامريكي كبير جدا لاوكرانيا وهناك الدعم
المالي ايضا لذلك نعتقد ان هذا الدعم
سيستمر
العسكري والاستراتيجي بموسكو شكرا جزيلا
لك